Trascrizione: Massimo Garzotto
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera.
Spesso, una delle domande che mi fanno è:
qual è la mia fotografia preferita,
quella più forte, quella più bella.
Io correggo: quelle necessarie.
Per molto tempo ho cercato
di narrare, condividere
alcune delle foto a cui sono più legato.
Poi ho cambiato, ho cercato
di non raccontarle più,
ho anche smesso, forse,
un po' di mentirmi.
Quindi ho iniziato a parlare
delle fotografie più dolorose,
quelle non fatte,
le fotografie dove arrivi troppo tardi,
dove l’unica cosa da fotografare
è una barca con l’assenza delle persone,
l’odore della benzina
o qualche corpo da recuperare.
(Suoni di registrazioni audio)
Mi chiamo Francesco Malavolta,
sono un fotografo - o se preferite,
un fotogiornalista -
e oggi cercherò,
attraverso le mie fotografie,
di raccontare alcune storie.
In realtà, io sono un mezzo,
e quindi dico sempre
che le storie, o meglio quelle foto,
non appartengono a me, ma appartengono
alle persone fotografate.
L’etica giornalistica ci impone
di raccontare sempre la verità.
Nel mio caso, da fotografo,
di dire esattamente cosa c’è
all'interno di una fotografia.
È facile, comunque, guardare
all’interno di una fotografia
perché basta, comunque,
osservare i dettagli;
e per un fotografo, a volte,
la scelta è semplicemente
che decide cosa fotografare.
È molto più complicato, invece,
narrare, raccontare cosa non c’è
dietro una fotografia,
cosa non c’è nella fotografia.
La narrazione, soprattutto,
dei flussi migratori,
dei popoli in movimento, dei profughi.
si è sempre concentrata
in uno spazio temporale
che va dalla barca in difficoltà,
dal naufragio con le vittime,
quindi numeri,
dal soccorso, dallo sbarco nel porto,
e dalle polemiche:
non c’è mai un prima,
non c’è mai un dopo.
La mia responsabilità, quindi, qual è?
Quella di raccontarle.
Raccontarle con delle storie,
cercare di entrare nei particolari.
Ecco perché oggi
abbiamo scelto sei fotografie -
una volta, una gallerista
mi ha detto: ma non sono belle!
Però, in quelle sei fotografie
io ho trovato una forza incredibile,
che adesso naturalmente cercheremo
di osservarle insieme.
La prima fotografia
è l’isola di Lesbo nel 2015.
Questa giovane mamma siriana
a distanza vedo che stava,
con una cassetta di polistirolo,
quella del pesce,
e del nastro.
Io non riuscivo a credere
a quello che, naturalmente,
la mia macchina fotografica
inizialmente mi faceva vedere.
Mi sono avvicinato, ed era
esattamente quello che pensavo:
Una madre che, non trovando più giubbotti
di salvataggio in Turchia,
ha deciso di costruire
un giubbotto alla sua piccola
con delle cassette e del nastro.
Qualcosa che solo una mamma può fare.
Se guardate ancora più
in profondità, in questa foto,
l’unica parte che era interessante
di tutto quello che c’era da fotografare,
vedete la delicatezza con cui la mamma
avvolge il nastro alla bambina,
che tiene la mamma per paura di perderla;
e il fratello che dà una mano
dall’altra parte.
Questa bambina probabilmente,
nei suoi anni trascorsi,
non ha mai avuto dei compagni di scuola,
se non all’interno dei campi di transito
prima di arrivare in Grecia.
La seconda foto invece è fatta nel 2016,
ero a bordo di una nave
una giornata molto particolare,
particolare sia per il numero
delle persone salvate, quasi mille,
sia purtroppo per i corpi recuperati: 22.
Quando si recuperano dei corpi,
il viaggio di ritorno verso un porto
è sempre complicato,
è complicato perché a bordo,
spessissimo, ci sono dei parenti;
ed è un dolore che non vivono solo loro,
ma vive l’intero equipaggio;
e anche chi, come nel mio caso,
è lì per documentare
comunque ne prende quel dolore;
spessissimo è capitato,
su barche  molto più piccole,
di riposare, pochissimi minuti,
e a fianco al mio oblò,
dal finestrino dove si affaccia sul mare,
la parte sotto con dei sacchi,
con dei cadaveri,
spesso di bambine, bambini, donne, uomini,
di cui non si conosce la storia
e la storia non ci racconterà
mai nulla di loro.
In questo caso, mi sono soffermato
con lo sguardo verso questo ragazzo:
un sopravvissuto, un fortunato, un rinato;
e il particolare non sono solo
i suoi occhi persi nel vuoto,
ma quel numero che aveva scritto
prima della partenza dalla Libia,
da contattare in caso di morte.
Un numero di telefono di parenti,
da chiamare per dire: suo figlio,
il suo compagno, suo fratello è morto.
Era già capitato altre volte,
durante l’ispezione dei cadaveri
nei porti, soprattutto siciliani,
ma erano fogli di carta dove i numeri
erano completamente illeggibili
perché l’acqua li aveva rovinati.
La terza foto in realtà
è una foto fatta sempre
sull’isola di Lesbo nel 2015;
in questo caso io non ho fatto
nessuna domanda alla famiglia,
sono rimasto anche abbastanza distante,
ho utilizzato un obiettivo,
una lunga lente.
Era troppo intima.
Allora ho immaginato la storia:
e se è vero che noi giornalisti
dobbiamo dire sempre la verità,
io sono sicuro che questa storia,
che mi sono immaginato, è quella reale.
Questo padre, sbarcato
sull’isola di Lesbo,
a un certo punto crolla,
e scoppia in un pianto incredibile
dove arriva la sua piccola,
e non fa altro che accarezzare
il volto del papà,
cercando di incoraggiarlo.
Io mi sono immaginato questo papà,
che ha portato via,
dalla Siria bombardata,
questa piccola con la sua famiglia;
e a un certo punto,
dopo averla protetta per tutto il viaggio,
il lungo viaggio, il viaggio
di cui non si parla mai,
arrivato in Grecia è crollato,
è crollato perché comunque aveva
dato vita, rinascita alla sua famiglia.
L’altra foto invece,
di cui non si parla mai, sono le cause:
se c’è una migrazione
è perché ci sono delle cause,
quel prima e quel dopo;
in questo caso ero
in Burkina Faso, tre anni fa,
e avevo necessità anch’io di scendere
all’interno di questi buchi,
fino a 20 metri sottoterra.
Sono delle miniere informali,
circa 400 in Burkina Faso,
dove ci sono questi ragazzini
che cercano delle pietre
per poi tirare su:
ogni cinque sacchi, uno va al gruppo.
Ma il rischio è troppo di non trovare oro.
Allora loro barattano,
neanche coi due dollari
al giorno, ma con del riso:
il buco dove sono entrato
era 70 centimetri per 70.
Per un fotografo è necessario
avere tanta attrezzatura;
io ho dovuto scegliere solo
una macchina fotografica e un obiettivo.
Quell’oro che poi alla fine arriva
dalle 400 miniere informali
fa un giro stranissimo, all’interno
del Burkina Faso, di riciclaggio,
per poi passare nelle miniere ufficiali;
e finisce sulla nostra pelle:
nei nostri orecchini,
nei nostri bracciali,
nelle nostre cinture.
Tutto quello che comunque
può servire per quel materiale.
L’altra foto è, invece, una foto del 2011:
è una foto dove questo giovane ragazzo,
che non ha voluto dichiarare,
per motivi di sicurezza,
il luogo di provenienza,
probabilmente un nigeriano,
aveva una vita -
ci ha raccontato la sua storia
una volta sbarcato sull’isola
di Lampedusa, con altri 250.
Aveva una vita normale,
aveva una vita anzi più che normale:
dei soldi, un ottimo posto di lavoro,
una vita sociale importante -
proprio perché in quei Paesi,
in molti paesi, sotto dittatura,
i diritti umani cambiano velocemente:
lui ha sentito il pericolo,
quindi ha deciso di fare
il viaggio verso la Libia.
Naturalmente ha pagato
i trafficanti "velocemente",
cioè ha dato il doppio per cercare
di arrivare in Libia,
c’era Gheddafi, come dice lui, "in fuga",
ed è riuscito ad arrivare a Lampedusa.
Lui già sapeva di essere inserito
all’interno del centro di accoglienza,
e di ricevere la tuta che davano a tutti;
lui ha voluto portare
questo messaggio di dignità.
La foto, naturalmente,
poi è stata utilizzata
da un ricercatore inglese,
dove hanno trasformato, su una barca,
250 persone in giacca e cravatta;
e gli intervistati, vedendo 250 persone
in giacca e cravatta,
avevano meno paura
se escludevano lui dalla barca.
Ultima foto, e qui
c’è pochissimo da raccontare.
Sono arrivato, uno dei primi,
il tre ottobre del 2013, a Lampedusa,
dove morirono 368 persone.
In questo caso ci arrivò disposizione
che nessun fotografo e giornalista
poteva entrare all'interno
dell'hangar dell'aeroporto.
Poi grazie a delle pressioni
non solo nazionali ma internazionali,
ci hanno fatto entrare.
È lì che, per la prima volta,
l’opinione pubblica ha visto
368 bare in fila,
e non solo numeri.
La prima volta che veniva dato
alla stampa internazionale e mondiale
la visibilità di cosa significa
trovare delle persone morte
all’interno di un hangar.
Al nono giorno recuperarono
la 368esima vittima,
con ancora il feto attaccato,
a 47 metri di profondità.
Allora qui il mio obiettivo da fotografo,
scusate il termine, era uno:
far entrare più bare possibili
all’interno di quella fotografia.
Raccontarla e raccontare, anche,
le storie dei sopravvissuti
che ho incontrato
poi successivamente negli anni.
Beh l’impatto della fotografia,
e la responsabilità di un fotografo,
è molto importante.
Basta pensare alla morte di Alan Kurdi,
sulla spiaggia di Bodrum,
nel 2015.
Be', quella sofferenza,
quella foto sofferta,
fatta da una fotografa turca
che si è fatta delle domande
se pubblicarla o non pubblicarla,
ha in pratica dato il via,
da parte della Germania,
all’apertura di un corridoio
per oltre mezzo milione di persone.
La gente che transitava
dalla Grecia verso la Germania,
tra il 2015 e il 2016,
a ogni confine era lì a ringraziare
la Germania e la Merkel.
È anche vero, ritornando
alla responsabilità delle fotografie,
che la maggior parte
delle fotografie, purtroppo,
che arrivano sui social,
o sui giornali, nei telegiornali,
non sono fatte da professionisti,
e questo è un grandissimo problema.
Perché un professionista -
io ogni volta che faccio una foto,
ogni volta che seleziono
soprattutto una foto,
decido di condividerla
con il mio committente,
o anche su un social,
mi chiedo se ha senso
pubblicare quella foto.
Se rispetto la dignità di quella persona,
se quella foto può cambiare
qualcosa o meno.
Soprattutto se si tratta di corpi,
faccio molta attenzione
a non prendere degli elementi
che possono comunque portare
la notizia della morte
a un parente, dall’altra parte del mondo,
che nemmeno sa che suo figlio,
o sua figlia, hanno intrapreso un viaggio.
E quindi, naturalmente,
la necessità e l'attenzione.
La sofferenza delle mie foto:
io so che le mie foto
sono cariche di sofferenza;
però da oggi, credo,
anche un po’ le vostre.
Mi chiamo Francesco, sono un fotografo
e da moltissimi anni
io non faccio più il bagno.
Grazie.
(Applausi)